DOESN'T IT SEEM LIKE THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF EARTHQUAKES LATELY?
THAT'S CAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN, SO DOES THIS
MEAN THIS BIG ONE'S COMING?
AND WHAT CAN YOU DO ABOUT IT?
HEY GUYS THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE STRUCK OFF THE COAST OF
CHILE THIS WEEK, TRIGGERING 7 FT TSUNAMIS
AND MASS EVACUATIONS ALONG THE COUNTRY'S COASTAL
AREAS.
THE 8.2 QUAKE NEAR CHILE COMES ON THE HEELS
OF SEVERAL SMALLER QUAKES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY...BROUGHT TO LIFE BY THIS ONE AMAZING
VIRAL VIDEO OF TWO NEWS ANCHORS FROM KTLA
BASICALLY NAILING EARTHQUAKE SAFETY PROTOCOL...
FORTUNATELY, NO MAJOR DAMAGE IN EITHER CALIFORNIA
OR CHILE IS REPORTED AT THIS POINT...BUT IT'S
RAISED ALARM AMONG SOME FOLKS THAT A "BIG
ONE" IS COMING....A "BIG ONE" LIKE THE LA
NORTHRIDGE QUAKE IN 1994, WHICH KILLED DOZENS
AND CAUSED 42 BILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGE...OR
LOMA PRIETA IN SAN FRANCISCO IN 1989, WHICH
KILLED 63 AND BADLY EFFED UP INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE BAY AREA.
OF COURSE, THERE HAVE BEEN FAR WORSE QUAKES
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD - LIKE THE 2010
QUAKE THAT DEVASTATED HAITI.
CAN WE PREDICT WHEN MAJOR QUAKES WILL HAPPEN?
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS POINT, ONLY VERY VERY
GENERALLY.
QUAKES ARE CAUSED BY SHIFTING TECTONIC PLATES,
AND THE AREAS MOST AT RISK ARE PLACES THAT
SIT ALONG THESE FAULT LINES.
BUT THAT RISK CAN BE AGGRAVATED BY MAN-MADE
FACTORS THAT CAN EXERT EXTRA PRESSURE ON NATURALLY
OCCURRING SEISMIC ACTIVITY.
THE BEST KNOWN EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE Sichuan
PROVINCE OF CHINA, WHICH HAD A MAJOR QUAKE
IN 2008 THAT'S BELIEVED TO HAVE BEEN TRIGGERED
IN PART BY A DAM IN THE AREA.
BECAUSE OF THE MANY POTENTIAL TRIGGERS - WHICH
COULD INCLUDE ANYTHING FROM RESERVOIRS, MINING
OR FRACKING - SCIENTISTS CAN IDENTIFY PARTS
OF THE WORLD THAT ARE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
A QUAKE, BUT CAN'T SAY WHEN THEY WILL HAPPEN
WITH ANY USEFUL LEVEL OF ACCURACY.
IN FACT, ANIMALS MIGHT BE MUCH BETTER AT SENSING
QUAKES THAN HUMANS.
JUST BEFORE A 2009 QUAKE IN ITALY FOR EXAMPLE,
96% OF MALE TOADS DITCHED THEIR BREEDING SITE
IN THE AREA JUST DAYS BEFORE THE QUAKE.
BUT CAN WE PREPARE FOR AN EARTHQUAKE...SURE.
IN PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA OR CHILE THAT BASICALLY
SIT ON ACTIVE FAULTS, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
GOTTEN BETTER AT PREPPING INFRASTRUCTURE - AND
PEOPLE - FOR MAJOR JOLTS.
IN THE BAY AREA FOR EXAMPLE, ENGINEERS SPENT
YEARS RETROFITTING THE BAY BRIDGE TO OAKLAND
WITH ADDITIONAL DIAGONALS AND OTHER FEATURES
THAT CAN HELP CUSHION AGAINST THE SIDE TO
SIDE ROCKING THAT CAN CAUSE FAILURE.
BUT NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE, YOU SHOULD KNOW
WHAT NOT TO DO IN THE EVENT OF A QUAKE.
FEEL FREE TO MILDLY FREAK OUT - LIKE OUR NEWS
ANCHOR FRIENDS - BUT PLEASE RESIST THE URGE
TO RUN SCREAMING INTO THE STREET DURING AN
EARTHQUAKE, AS OUR INTERN KENNY KINDLY DEMONSTRATES
FOR US HERE.
YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO GET HIT WITH FALLING
OBJECTS THAT CAN HARM YOU THAT WAY.
YOUR BEST BET IS TO DUCK AND COVER UNDER A
DESK OR TABLE, OR STAND IN A DOORWAY.
IF YOU'RE OUTSIDE, GET OUT IN THE OPEN AWAY
FROM POWER LINES OR OTHER THINGS THAT COULD
FALL ON YOU.
AND AS WITH ANY POTENTIAL EMERGENCY, IT CAN'T
HURT TO HAVE SOME BASIC SUPPLIES AROUND YOUR
HOME IN THE EVENT OF POWER FAILURE.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED, WE'LL LEAVE SOME OTHER
RESOURCES IN THE LINKS BELOW.
HAVE YOU LIVED THROUGH AN EARTHQUAKE OR OTHER
DISASTER?
IF SO I'D LOVE TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE.
YOU CAN GET IN TOUCH WITH THE SHOW ON TWITTER
AT DNEWS OR ON FACEBOOK AT DISCOVERY NEWS.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND ME PERSONALLY AT ANNIEGAUS
ON TWITTER AND AT MY OTHER SHOW, WHATS THE
BIG DEAL.
THANKS FOR WATCHING AND SEE YOU NEXT TIME.